if you like action movies and you also
like John restore ease that dig into one
key conceptual hook and its many
implications along the way the old guard
is a film for youth from how it wraps up
to where it might go next this is the
ending of the old guard explained here's
your warning spoilers ahead for the old
guard the chief threat of the old guard
is marek a pharmaceutical tycoon who
becomes convinced that Andy and her near
immortal crew are the key to opening up
all sorts of pathways to curing disease
slowing the aging process and perhaps
even stopping death Merrick has vast
financial resources tremendous tenacity
and the help of cop Lee's research he
also has Booker's help and with all of
that at his back he's very nearly able
to capture and incapacitate every single
member of the old guard of course by the
end of the film Merrick has fallen out
of his own skyscraper with an axe in his
neck so he won't be coming after them
again any time soon that said as Andy
notes near the end of the film it's
almost impossible to stay hidden in the
modern world they live in
if Merrick was able to track him down
and deploy his wealth to very nearly
caged them all who's to say an even
wealthier business tycoon somewhere
can't do the same particularly after
they learn about what Merrick went
through all it takes is one person with
knowledge of the team who's willing to
say what they know when we first meet
Nylund she's an American Marine just
trying to do her best who discovers
quite by accident that she's immortal
much of the film's emotional core is
devoted to denial coming to terms with
her abilities and the massive
implications they have including what it
means for her relationship with her
loved ones as the other members of the
old guard explained if she tries to keep
in touch with her family and stay with
them until they die they'll grow to
resent her they will never forget
hey now despair in their eyes still now
persists in her desire to keep in
contact with her family to the point
that Andi even relents and gives her
back her phone in the end nyle chooses
her new family of immortals but reveals
in the final scenes of the film that she
still has her phone and therefore still
has a lifeline to her family even though
Copley has promised to make it look like
she was killed in action though nyle
seems content with finding her way as an
immortal it's very possible she'll seek
out her family again even after her
family learns of her presumed death it's
possible she won't be able to resist and
will open a box that she finds very hard
to close from the beginning of the film
it's clear that the old guard values
their privacy and he goes so far as to
offer to take a photo for some tourists
just so she can delete a picture she
happened to be in the background of then
of course Copley reveals that he's been
doing research on them going back
decades
complete with photographs old ID cards
news clippings and much more as penance
for his attempts to sell them off to
Marek
she tasks Copley with becoming their new
eraser of sorts he will be in charge not
just of helping them coordinate new
missions but of erasing every trace that
they were there in the first place by
the end of the film the old guard has a
new and powerful layer of secrecy in
their corner though Marek is the chief
villain of the old guard he's not alone
in his journey to capturing the crew and
learning their secrets arguably the most
important ingredient is Booker's
betrayal Andi and her crew very nearly
go down because her best friend and
fellow immortal decides it's worth it to
turn them all over to medical
researchers in the hope that one day
they'll learn how to finally die by the
end of the film Andi has found new
purpose in life after her struggle with
Marek and while she shares a part of
that with Booker the group still votes
to punish him by exiling him from the
team 100 years Rita day they'll meet new
year
till they are alive but just as he's
preparing himself for a lonely century
Andy's old partner Gwyn tracks him down
presumably to use him to get to Andy
again
Booker already betrayed the old guard
once with the potential unstable
immortal now hunting him down will he do
it again
Gwen's return is brief so there's still
a great deal we don't know about her
what we do know is that she's been
through a lot
she suffered a kind of torture that
mortal humans can only imagine and it
probably hasn't done anything good for
her mental state there's no doubt that
she'll at least put Booker in a
difficult position
whatever her plans may be the members of
the old guard know they can die they
just never know when each time they go
down in a fight could be the last but
none of them has any idea what triggers
that final death or what the signs are
near the end of the film
Andy realizes that she has lost her own
grip on immortality
when Booker's shot to her stomach
refuses to heal though she's apparently
now vulnerable enough that she could be
killed
Andy is at peace by the end of the film
she sees her newfound mortality is a
trade-off for Niles emergence as the
first new immortal among them in ages
seeing her young sister in arms fills
her with a new sense of wonder and
seeing cop Lee's research into her past
reveals to her that she has a purpose
she can still serve while she lives so
with all that in mind how much longer
does Andy actually have left will she
aged conventionally and die in a few
decades
Booker seems to think that's the case
though she seems to know something we
don't
telling him to have faked is it possible
that her lingering gifts could prolong
her life or even make her somewhat
harder to kill than a normal human we
don't know but Andy's definitely not
done testing her limits the members of
the old guard know quite a lot about how
their immortality works they know that
it is finite they know that they dream
of each other when they're apart and
they know that they are rare what they
don't know is why they've been given
these strange gifts and others habits by
the end of the film Copley has shown
them why in the course of his research
into the old guard he discovers that
Andy and her crew have a ripple effect
on people they save on missions if they
rescue someone that person's descendants
will do something great in the world
creating a cumulative good
multiplies the longer they stay alive
she saves a life to three generations
later we reap the benefits this
discovery is perhaps the most important
driving factor in the entire film
because it confirms for Andi that she
still has something worth living for the
world might be getting worse but she has
a palpable power to make it better
and so the crew sets out at the end with
a renewed sense of purpose even though
they still don't have all the answers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]